[Música]
y bueno para mí aunque no soy no estoy
en el arte escénico también es un poco
es un poco no problemático porque hay
que adaptarse pero si estaba preguntando
no me puedo mover de aquí tengo que
estar dentro del círculo organismo sí
porque ahí está la luz y ahí está el
vídeo así que voy a hacer mi mejor
esfuerzo
bueno para quienes no me conocen pues yo
me llamo maría susana rivadeneira soy
ecuatoriana nací en quito vivo en
guayaquil por ahí está mi mamá
es mi rumba tango de kiss
y bueno soy artista plástica en realidad
me preguntaba joaquín y tú qué haces
digo es una pregunta de las más
difíciles que me hacen porque soy súper
inquieta y tiendo a hacer muchas cosas
me gusta el arte me gusta la pintura me
gusta la gastronomía nuestra comida la
peruana es muy rica fue la ecuatoriana
es aún mejor si o no
a ver cómo qué plato así el más rico de
todos
al rato menestra
y un baloncito me invitó a sus
conferencias ya sus pláticas un
baloncito ya me había comprado bueno
este también que les quería contar un
poco de mí soy directora de una
plataforma que realicé con mi hermano
porque bueno ustedes saben nada se hace
sola tengo un equipo aunque chiquito
pues muy muy nutrido en ideas y en en
ganas y con mi hermano carlos pues
trabajo hace ya diez o doce años en
design air book que es esta plataforma
que desarrolla la industria de la moda
de manera diferente de manera
acoplada a tratar de dar un granito de
arena
al mundo cómo a través del slow fashion
no a través del diseño sostenible y de
las nuevas ideas que puedan generar un
impacto porque ustedes dirán bueno pues
en la moda es como un escenario un tanto
frío un tanto facto pues light
pero yo creo que cada uno desde su
trinchera puede hacer puede ser un
agente de cambio entonces bueno eso es a
lo que me dedico y hace
decena de años en realidad son más de
diez años son doce y
y ya con 18 ediciones de más pero
realmente hoy día me voy a aprovechar
del pánico pánico escénico que también
estoy sintiendo ahorita pero decía pues
a guido que lo volvió un poco loco todos
seguidos ido arriba todo lo bueno me voy
a aprovechar un poco del momento porque
porque ahorita estoy de directora de un
proyecto que se llama reza lo pueden
buscar a través de las redes sociales
como reza punto refugio este es será es
el primer proyecto en guayaquil que
atiende a personas adultas con situación
de calle o sea que viven en situación de
indigencia tengo también hay un equipo
muy muy lindo de gente que se ha venido
involucrando y qué sé yo pues hemos
estado como dice monseñor con la
valentía de empezar y con la fuerza y la
valentía de continuar pero aunque a
veces es difícil dije me voy a ir a
parar ahí aunque me cueste un poquito
porque necesito voluntarios así que he
venido a buscarlos a todos
bueno no sé si me puedo ayudar
guido con el vídeo sin sonido por favor
y yo igual voy a ir narrando un poquito
de este proyecto y de lo que realmente
viene a hablar que es el tema de la
adaptación y de la actitud bueno eso fue
el día que inauguramos este sueño es un
sueño que hemos tenido con un grupo de
amigos empresarios hace ya algunos años
estamos ubicados en la parroquia el
santísimo sacramento somos del techo de
la iglesia junto al mercado de las
cuatro manzanas quien ha ido quien
conoce el mercado a las cuatro manzanas
levanten la mano no más levante que ya
ahorita ya todos hemos ido al mercado de
las cuatro manzanas bueno ahí nosotros
tenemos ahorita bueno han pasado más o
menos ya unas cuarenta y pico de
personas digo han pasado porque como
ustedes saben ellos tienen una una
situación un tanto compleja no hay
momentos en los que quieren salir
adelante y hay otros en los que digamos
todos esos pesares y esas esa digo yo
esa jungla de asfalto a la cual se
enfrentan todos los días les impide
seguir adelante y han salido del refugio
sin embargo tenemos casos de reinserción
ya así que
pues yo decía pues aunque sea uno pues
ya está la misión cumplida y el corazón
contento pero gracias a dios son más de
uno así que tenemos todavía muchísima
esperanza bueno quería empezar con una
frase que a mí me encanta y me cuestiona
mucho
que dice así todo lo que hay en tu vida
tú lo permitiste tú lo deseaste o tú
mismo lo creaste
porque esta frase es tan cuestionado
ahora para mí porque considero que
en la vida y como lo decía luchó pues si
bien hay que adaptarse a las situaciones
también hay que empoderarse en lo que
uno quiere y sueña
y también lo que uno quiere
tiene que crearlo uno tiene que saber
que lo que uno cree lo puede crear y eso
tal vez sería como el mensaje que yo
podía traer este día es algo que yo hago
todos los días incluso creo mi día todos
los días y ahí es donde nosotros tenemos
que les invito a hacer el ejercicio
desde mañana que puedan levantarse y
decir bueno cómo va a ser mi día hoy y
qué es lo que quiero para mi día hoy
aquí y ahora en el presente porque a
veces tenemos esta tendencia que nos que
nos invita a estar pensando en lo que en
lo que no hicimos o en lo que tenemos
que hacer y eso nos genera angustia o
frustración y nos olvidamos de lo más
lindo que es el hoy el presente este
momento esta alfombra roja estas caras
que estoy viendo y este compartir no
entonces es súper importante poder
entender que estamos aquí hoy y que hoy
es el momento de poder dar lo mejor que
nosotros podemos dar y también decidir
en qué grupo de personas vamos a estar
esto es algo que yo hablo mucho con la
gente que tiene situación de calle
porque a veces de ellos de hecho el otro
es justo uno me decía el martes justo me
decía pero reinita no se rinda reinita
pero usted a venir acá y de regresar a
su casa bien texto no le digo no al ex
por qué por qué porque usted cree que yo
voy a regresar dice no pues porque usted
sabe nosotros pues le cargamos de tantas
penas y tantos problemas y tanto no me
regreso mi caso triste yo muy bien
contento a mi casa porque eres tú el que
decide cómo quieres estar en tu día y
eres tú el que decide cómo quieres estar
en tu vida si tú quieres que yo sienta
pena y compasión de ti ese es tu
problema eso no es mi problema y yo me
voy tranquila y contenta porque estoy
haciendo lo que a mí me gusta tú tienes
que decidir qué es lo que tú quieres
hacer si quieres estar
en el grupo de las víctimas o en el
grupo de los protagonistas entonces ahí
esa reflexión
a mí me incluso que esa la diga él me
ayuda mucho a mí porque de todas maneras
una vez es en el día a día te olvidas de
las cosas que tienes que hacer y tu
enfoque se va se va diluyendo con los
problemas
porque quien diga que no tiene el
problema de esta a ver quién quien
considera que de repente en el día tiene
problemas quien quien a veces tiene que
resolver cosas levanten la mano a ver
y hay unos que no levantan la mano no
tienen que pagar la luz de su casa el
ies no él tiene que ir a comprar la
comida
verdad que si todos tenemos que resolver
algo aunque sea inmediato aunque sea
chiquito que sea mediano lo que sea pero
nos de nosotros depende la actitud que
vamos a tener no de repente no sé si han
visto ese tipo de gente que de repente
todos pasamos en ese proceso porque
podemos ser esas personas que voy a
detallar ahorita este
en el mismo día incluso cuando tú te
levantas y dices ay pues hay
al espejo y sal gorda este o no sé ni un
grano aquí me ha salido este horrible
este no se puede los que están casados
pues no sé dirás a este esposo mío que
no se levanta o mi esposa ya no la
aguanto esta actitud que tiene estar
brava todo el día y de repente ya te
sientes de comer y hay de esto yo quería
otra cosa capaz de un baloncito que pasa
es que este pan que está duro ya y
cuando sales a la calle y te enfrento de
la caixa y no te taxista que se me
atraviesa ojalá que se tape por ahí
aquino quien no tenía uno de esos días
levante la mano que haya tenido nuestros
días
totalmente
pero también de nosotros depende
levantar y claro llegas a la oficina
llegas a tu trabajo llegas a la
fundación a donde tú te desenvuelvas y
dices híjole y ahora que más largo nacho
hoy día esta va a llover o hace calor
hay grillos todo ya y todo está hecho
una nube negra 7 con 14
hasta ese entonces ese es un tipo de
personas que seguramente nosotros somos
verdad pero de nosotros depende
controlar nuestros pensamientos y poner
atención porque nuestra mente no puede
controlar nos somos nosotros los que
tenemos que controlar soy yo la que
tengo que controlar mi mente pues se me
levanto el día y digo no es no decir qué
linda estoy puedo decir bueno ay qué
bien me siento y si estoy cansado no no
estoy casado con mi rumba y preciosa que
está ahí que me persigo enjugado talla
mami ya no lo hagas pero me lo tomé digo
qué lindo tener una mamá todavía lado
mía que me haga un jugo de papaya y
cuando salgo se me atraviesa el mismo
taxista hijo pero ya pobre hombre que
será que le está pasando cosas tiene
ganas de ir al baño por eso va tan
rápido ojalá no se estampe por ahí
verdad entonces han tenido ese día
también levanten la mano se han tenido
ese día bueno yo sí también ese es el
día que nosotros tenemos que procurar
tener porque a 22 veces levante la mano
muy bien
porque porque a la final de nosotros
depende mucho más de lo que nosotros
entendemos si yo estoy alegre no sé para
qué escribo de bragg miento lo que
escribí no leí donda
si yo estoy alegre yo no tengo ustedes
en el ejercicio porque es muy importante
cuando usted están alegres van
contagiando a las personas que están
alrededor suyo y no solamente las
personas que están cerca o quizás unas
23 personas nada ya no crean velo hay
más de 100 personas que van a responder
a esa actitud con la que usted se ha
levantado esa actitud positiva con la
que usted se ha levantado y asimismo
cuando uno se levanta hecho una nube
negra
y las mujeres a veces que en el mes
fecha es complejo
tenemos que tratar de controlar nuestra
mente y nuestro cuerpo que no nos
controle a nosotros que ese hito que
todos tenemos que a veces es como un
caballo desbocado no nos pase a llevar
ese mismo ego que lo necesitamos porque
es el que nos alerta el que nos dice no
sea mala un minutito más del 5 me dijo
ahorita no me vaya a cambiar con el de
tres entonces ese caballo que de repente
se desboca y aún no lo lleva a estar
malhumorado y
bueno y muchas otras cosas egoísta bueno
infeliz al final
pero cuando nosotros controlamos ese ego
que si lo necesitamos porque él es el
que te hace estar alerta es el que te
dice a ver no bajes por aquí porque como
eres mediática cuidado te caes no cruces
sin mirar los dos lados porque de
repente te
te pueden atropellar eso eso es lo que
lo que me ayuda a que yo pueda
sobrevivir de alguna manera pero él
tiene que estar domado él tiene que
estar calmado aquí aquí abajo cuando él
empieza a hacer de las suyas el que
nosotros empezamos
a estar en felices y ahí habría que ahí
habría que entender
qué es el amor verdad
que yo lo escribí aquí digo pues no es
un sentimiento porque a veces cuando
dice que el amor es un sentimiento
benito que te hace que la pasión no es
un estado de comprensión total es un
estado de conciencia cuando yo veía los
vídeos que nos mostraba joaquín y cuando
escuché cantar a la señorita y cuando
estaba aquí este súper tocando y cuando
vio a luchó y digo ese estado pleno de
estar consciente de las cosas que pasan
a mi alrededor y de poder valorar y
apreciar el arte el amor la dedicación
el trabajo el servicio eso es del amor
un estado de comprensión total que nos
deja paz interior
cuando me queda ver 2 con 53
tengo que tengo que escoger bueno otra
de las cosas que quería decirles yo es
y también
un mensaje que les quiero dejarles hoy
es el mañana del que tanto me preocupaba
ayer eso en virtud de que vivamos el
presente hagamos lo mejor que podamos
dejemos todo a los que son emprendedores
emprendan no les dé miedo que el piso no
pasa a los que quieren hacer trabajo
social idea el amigo le dice silla le
hace sí sí
exacto rodense de gente buena de buenos
amigos que puedan decirle sí dale pana
hace esto estás bien adelante a la gente
que esté a tóxica
bueno con cariño y con ternura hagan a
un lado no necesitamos de esa gente
necesitamos rodearnos de gente que
quiera cambiar el mundo que quiera hacer
la gente cambio desde cualquier
trinchera hoy día imaginas en todo el
menú de ponentes que hemos tenido o sea
desde los jardines esté con los niños
desde el trabajo con computadoras todo
el tema de
y tres de impresiones tres de arte
música todo el mundo un poquito
discrepando con lo que con una de las
conferencias que nos mostraron de manera
virtual
no nos ocupemos solo del cuerpo
en relación al señor que tenía sus dos
piernas biónicas la ciencia y la
tecnología están a nuestro servicio pero
seamos muy sabios en usarla porque si no
como decía mi mamá en el intermedio que
iba a pasar después vamos a tener
personas aladas biónicas que van a ser
superhéroes y que van a y que solo van a
estar ocupados y preocupados de su
cuerpo y de iu entienden o sea no somos
mucho más allá que un cuerpo es más
estamos sólo de paso aquí esto es
solamente un instrumento que nosotros
tenemos para dejar este mundo mejor
entonces
ocupémonos de lo fundamental con amor y
con humor
sin prisa
sin prisa pero bien
bien esté bien ocupados de que eso es lo
que tenemos que hacer con un propósito
de vida ayudemos al que lo necesita que
para eso estamos aquí agradecer a 177 16
15 14
agradecerles incluso a esta instancia de
poder compartir estas experiencias de
darme la oportunidad de aprender y
también de convocar así que ya saben a
las personas que quieran servir y que
quieran hacer y conocer el proyecto de
reza refugio lo pueden buscar a través
de las redes sociales nuevamente se la
repito reza punto refugio
y bueno muchísimas gracias por este
espacio